The joe rogan experience.
You know, it's funny.
In 1985 I lived in a building in Fort
Lee and there was a Panamanian woman and
she told me that she went to Cuba twice
as a young girl and she wasn't surprised
what was going on in Cuba. That
was God's punishment. She goes,
it was such a disgusting fucking place.
And then it was weird. A couple
of days after, I'm talking to Tj,
uh,
somebody on Facebook.
I did a joke from my CSO special about
club 38 the owner name was Willie Vandy.
And his claim to fame was that his
grandfather had the biggest dick in Cuba.
I grew up with two kids that had
a claim to fame. One of them,
his dad was the best pool player in
Cuba and Americans will go down and he'd
beat the fuck out of him and pull you,
but they played Chicago eight ball
when I'm in Chicago. The other guy,
his claim to fame was that his grandfather
was the guy in godfather two who had
the big Dick and they called him superman
and Saturday nights at club 38 in
union city,
he would on Saturdays he recreated and
he's had people come down and it'd be
like a comedy show, $10 ticket and 200
people. He would get some coke out,
chick tire up to Cubans like that would
play the congress and he'd come out and
fuck the lady in public,
just go crazy with the biggest dick in
the world and my job fucker and public.
That was a whole thing. That was the
whole thing. That was a public fuck show,
but it went all the way back to Cuba to
like 55 like the name of the place was
the Shanghai,
the Shanghai Theater and and then
then godfather to Michael takes,
they take Michael there and
all of a sudden he goes,
I would have never found this place if
it wasn't for Johnny Ola and that's when
Michael finds out that he betrayed
them so they don't show the guys pick.
Then simpler if the guy with the big
Dick was also the greatest pool player
because he could just, Oh my God.
Yeah, that would have been perfect.
So they did this article
about two weeks ago.
It's on my Facebook and it's called
in search of Superman, Joe Rogan.
It was the most disgusting article I had
ever read in my life that these white
dudes went on a 50 year
looking for superman and the
legend of the guy with the
big thick. In fact, do val
went to Cuba to the location,
even though it's close,
just to see where it was and what the
story is that us as Americans will go down
there every week and that was our first
time to see this big black Cuban dude.
Fuck the shit out of some poor white
chick, you know, yelling and screaming.
The place was sold out every night.
I mean, the guy was a gardener.
The article is sensational, or if you
could find it, it's called in search.
You're superman and they is it there?
The Superman of a vagina.
But when it came out the same
week that they said that,
what are you fucking crazy?
They ain't no fake. That's real.
That's why they call him superman.
Afraid know. I saw, I saw
a video of Superman when I was
researching Havana Nocturne.
I found out that Santo traffic content
had a lawyer named Sam Rogano since
deceased,
but Sam Ogana used to take a lot of super
eight videos when he'd go down to Cuba.
His son,
who's currently a a lawyer in Tampa told
me that he had super eight footage of
superman that his father had made in
the 50s superman at a private sex show.
Fucking a girl. And I said, Ooh, I got
to see that. Could I see that? I mean,
I think that's the only existing
video footage anywhere of Superman.
And he said, yeah, but I'm
not going to give it up.
You got to come to Tampa and I'll
show it for you. So I go down there,
I'll never forget,
he's a lawyer too.
He says he got to come at six o'clock
after the, after the office closes.
So then we can watch it. And I get
there and the cleaning lady still there,
so he brings me into a conference room
where he's going to show me the film and
we got to sit there and wait until the
cleaning lady's done because he didn't
want to put this film
on while the Clinton,
while the cleaning ladies in the room,
so he puts it on the plates to office
is completely empty and he shows me this
footage and his father had scored it to
like Wagner or Beethoven like triumph
and classical music and it's, it's at a
private show. It's in somebody's home.
They had private sex salons in Havana
where you'd go to like some rich person's
house,
you'd pay some money,
you had cocktails and then someone had
clap at a certain time and you knew that
was time for the show and everyone would
sit down and superman would come out
and he, he, he fucked this. A
Cuban woman who was, who was small,
he was big and she was small and he's
banging her from every conceivable angle.
It was the least sexy thing you've
ever seen in your life. I mean,
it looked like a, it looked like
some kind of torture really.
Uh, and that was it. And
this guy had this footage,
which is probably worth a lot of models.
Big was the Dick. The Dick was big.
It wasn't, no, I say that because
it wasn't like I wasn't the,
I'm not sure it was even the
biggest stick I've ever seen.
I mean it was bigger than
my dad's bigger than normal.
It was bigger than the guys today.
It's almost like athletes.
Like if you go back and look at, you
know, when Jim Brown was playing football,
he was very impressive. But was he
Herschel Walker? You know what I'm saying?
Like athletes of today's era or different,
and if you go back and look at John
Holmes, yeah, he had a big Dick,
but was it Lexington steel? You know,
like these guys have bigger dicks now,
but the people are that they're
board vex people are growing.
The thing that freaked me out of the
human feces is advancing dancing.
But then that frequent about Santo that
I enjoyed from your first book of analog
turn. And I wanted to tell Joe the stories
that one time Kelly went to cash, uh,
Cuba as a senator and they were having
type of meeting but fucking Kennedy can
focus bro.
He just like it and that they like,
what the fuck is wrong with Monsanto
traffic camping because I know exactly
what's wrong.
Come on.
And they tapped him on the shoulder
and they bring them in the room.
He's embellishing this. Tell me, this
is what I remember. This is better.
This is what I remember I read.
And that I guess sat though,
he's sick them on two women
candidate while he set up. He said,
no, they didn't film it. They wish,
they wish they had filmed that.
They said they set him up in a room when
the two way mirror and they watched it
happening. And then one of them
said, Shit, we should've filmed this.
This would make great blackmail
material. Right. Well,
like Santo was kind of a freak.
So JFK cheers.
The freakiest the freaks,
right? Yeah. Well,
but you got to keep in mind he wasn't
married. He was a young senator.
He used to get this senator from Florida
named George Smathers and the two of
them would go down to Havana.
And this was around 1955 56 when
the whole thing was in its hay day.
And that was a big part of a van of
politicians and businessmen would go on
junkets to Havana, like you
know, paid for by the company.
Weekend Retreat,
go to Havana,
and they'd go to the Shanghai theater and
they had tris sexual triste and they'd
go crazy. And it was out of sight,
out of mind. It was the original,
you know what happens in Havana,
stays in a van.
It was all different country wasn't
going to make the newspapers.
So they go there and they rub elbows with
Santo traffic contact in Meyer Lansky
and they loved it. It was
exciting. It wouldn't,
it wouldn't do them any damage back home.
You know?
Amazing. When my mother
died in [inaudible] 79 and
whenever I did something,
like if I call my head differently
or if I wore like a, an orange shirt,
my mom would go, what are you
fucking rock Hudson? And I go,
what the fuck are you talking
about? Rock Hudson, you know,
and then one day I asked like, why do
you always call me and rock cuts him?
And she goes, cause rock Hudson,
I don't money go. And I go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
She told me she died in [inaudible] 79
my mom told me in 1978 flat out to my
face that fucking he was gay as could
be. And I'm like, you don't want,
I've heard I'm sick and tired of
you fucking Cubans. Because Cubans,
like they used to tell me when I was a
kid that they smacked Bruce Lee and Cuba
one time that he went down
there and talking to shit.
And one of my uncles smack them
in the face that, you know,
Cubans will lie to you just
to fucking fuck with you.
So I thought my mother was fucking
with me. She's like a rock concert.
Is this gay? Here's a $3 bill. And I
go, what the fuck are you talking about?
She goes, let me do what I'm talking
about. Right when I was a little girl,
rock cuts and would come to Cuba
and we would all go to the hotel.
You like when Michael Jackson goes to
a hotel, come outside and they clap.
He shook the kid outside the window.
We would be out there like
waiting to see rock cuts,
but the hotel guy would tell us he was
up there in a room with a man and I would
go, Ma, are you fucking crazy?
Like I didn't believe her.
My mother died in [inaudible] 79 85
rock Hudson comes on and says he's gay.
Like Campbell was just a hiding place for
people that want your mother know that
the Marlon Brando was
fucking Richard Pryor.
No one time found out from this article,
if we were to scroll down a little bit,
it says it,
that they asked his neighbors and the
neighbors were like, no, he was bisexual.
And then when his number one guy that
was known every time he came to Cuba was
Marlon Brando,
he was Marlon Brando would walking there
with to show girls and then him and
fucking superman would
leave by themselves.
So while Brando loved the music,
they play Congos all that shit.
He was really into it. Well,
Pryor's wife was saying that back then,
they were doing so much coke did.
Everybody just fucked everybody.
Everybody. That's just so crazy.
He couldn't make Jagger.
Fuck somebody like David Garrison.
That was one of Mick Jagger.
His wife said she caught David
Bowie and bed with Mick Jagger.
I know a lot of coke, but I never
wanted to fuck you up the ass Joe Rogan.
You know what I'm saying? Like
I never, I did a lot of coke.
I never want to fuck
another guy in the story.
Brando who was bisexual took off
with superman, ditching the dancers.
So Superman was a bisexual too.
In fact,
I heard he had died of
gangrene. Gangrene. Yeah.
And here it says that he infected.
Yeah. He died with a lover from sex.
Oh,
he slept around but gangrene from Sachs.
How hard you got to fuck
to get gang green maybe.
Fuck this chick that got shot in the ass.
He might've fucked animals.
Yeah. Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Was getting dirty,
Bro. Cuba was dirty. It was dirty.
Okay.